pourquoi le risque est-il devenu aussi
indésirable dans notre société
ça c'est la grande question il ya une
sorte de on peut dire de paradoxes du
risque c'est-à-dire que fait on est dans
des sociétés qui sont quand même
relativement sûr c'est à dire que si on
regarde objectivement les choses
l'espérance de vie est quand même en
progrès sur le long terme et les
violences les plus graves
ils ont largement diminué ya beaucoup de
maladies même si pour le coup
actuellement il ya quelques au vide qui
ont été vaincus donc objectivement
insécurité et les risques ne sont pas
forcément eu nombreux mayhem conscience
en effet du risque qui est beaucoup plus
plus grande aujourd'hui d'une capacité
de mesurer le le risque et on a la
capacité aujourd'hui aussi attendre
monde peut il ya des nouveaux riches et
notamment des risques mondialisée des
risques aussi qui ce sont des types de
réaliser dont on al impression qu on les
maîtrise moins a par exemple on pense à
la catastrophe de tchernobyl ou encore
tous les dangers ils ont trait aux
risques sanitaires aux dangers de l'eau
gm à l'action de l'amiante et donc on à
la fois un danger qui est mieux connue
mais moins peut-être du couquet paraît
moins maîtrisable et tout ceci menace
prédire comment on n'a pas forcément
prise sur ces risques là donc ça crée
une impression va d'une société du
risque vers une société où en effet le
risque est omniprésent et menaçant alors
même que finalement nos sociétés sont
heureux d'être plus sur lequel ne
l'était il ya deux siècles
[Musique]